so
cpac texas 2022 our correspondent luke
beasley was down there speaking to
people and it is absolutely
extraordinary now you can find luke's
youtube channel at davidpakman.com luke
to our podcast listeners you can also
find luke's audio podcast anywhere that
you are listening
i'm just going to present these to you
without too much introduction just a lot
of visible confusion
people who don't understand anything
people who don't know anything let's
take a look
and what do you think
the biggest failures of the bind
administration have been
oh gosh a lot
um
well
these pauses have not been extended for
effect just so everybody knows he says
that he has done things when he hasn't
such has contributed to
border security
i think for one thing
you know our president is biden but i
you know
there are other people who are actually
running our country not him
now i would at this point i would love
to say
who and i think that
a big thing
he said when he was running that he
wouldn't defund the police and he's done
that joe biden has not defunded the
police
and i think that's a huge reason why we
so see so much crime today i think that
biden has defunded the police where
well i mean he hasn't defunded them but
he's defined oh so the thing you just
said isn't true god did a lot of the
police he hasn't defunded the police
he's defunded a lot of the police nope
also not true and because that is done
on a city-wide level not the national
level
that's true that's true um but i mean
overall i think that
this is the scariest times that we have
lived in
all right well the one thing i mentioned
you're right it's not true but it's very
very scary right now regardless um then
luke interviewed you know another guy
let's listen uh who was a standout so
far and speakers uh i enjoyed quite a
few of the speakers so
you know
i mean ted cruz was certainly animated
yep we'll get to ted cruz in a moment
some some of the speakers i didn't
actually know but you know a lot of good
information
you know those types of things really
learned a lot
and uh obviously trump is about to speak
this evening
on that topic do you want him to run in
2024 uh i i would expect him to run you
know whether it's trump or desantis you
know somebody that cares about our
country is
you can tell trump deeply cares about
the future of the country that's his top
priority in all things that he does i
need it you know trump has stood in
front of the
the buzz saw that's been hitting our
country so we we do all our respects for
that he survived nancy pelosi's buzz saw
gratitude you know if he's going to
continue doing it and wins the
nomination and certainly support him
yeah
so i mean kind of lukewarm in a sense
support for trump this next one i'm not
going to play the whole thing because it
just it goes nowhere but it really just
shows you
like these people just have no idea
what's going on i don't understand how
they can even work a normal job and and
not get fired uh who have been some
standout speakers from your perspective
um
uh lauren bobert i don't know if i'm
saying kind of a congresswoman obviously
i love marjorie taylor green obviously
um
nigel farage obviously he's always great
he's always a great asset to cpac
getting the british voice in there um
the british conservative voice
so you mentioned that you
enjoyed marjorie taylor green and you
like her um
nail down for me because that always
baffles me what is it that resonates
with conservatives about marjory taylor
green
i think that she just
just is not afraid of speaking the truth
and not afraid of being politically
quote unquote incorrect marjorie taylor
green is one of the biggest liars out
there she invented the idea of that
there's a jewish space laser out there
she tells lies about vaccines she tells
lies about masks she tells lies about
joe biden she does lies about communism
she tells lies about everything what she
says is right i mean do i agree with
every single thing i nobody's black and
white everybody has areas of gray in
life life is grey
but i do think that her courage and most
republicans i hate to say this but most
republicans who've been in
the kind of in the fold for all these
decades and decades in politics they
kind of just
tout the same thing and they're full of
bull
no on my lifestyle
they're full of
they're just sitting on their you know
in their golden parachute they're
sitting in the golden parachute which is
really incredible all right so anyway
she kind of fumbled around for four
minutes then luke spoke to a younger guy
and it was
it was just as bad okay so we're outside
seat
and you're about to walk in who are you
hoping to see or who you're most excited
for i am excited to see trump for one
for two i also i'm excited to see steve
bannon
steve bannon
yeah
wow okay since you brought him up i this
wasn't uh steve bannon
was pardoned by trump right what he was
pardoned for
was defrauding
uh like donors because he was saying i'm
building a border wall wall and he
wasn't actually doing that he was uh
spending on like personal stuff that's
why i trump had to depart him i don't
understand because there's so many
people within the conservative movement
that i understand why you'd support them
they believe your things but they like
directly
defrauded the people that they now are
uh hoping to support them like how do
you forgive steve bannon for that
you know i still just listen to his
his podcast yeah i mean on his podcast
he didn't mention defrauding people he's
my mother and i just really like the way
he speaks about issues and i think he
brings up good points regarding
politics for one
generally based on what you've heard
from the january 6 committee what is
your sense of it and do any of those
facts make you less
positive towards trump well actually my
mother attended
the january 6 and it's bad people are
still locked up over it
my family actually got investigated by
the fbi for that
and they were just attending they
had nothing to do with they were
completely innocent going into the
capital right so anyway there's a guy
whose family went to the riots
and then here's one more guy who also
did the people they just seem perplexed
so i hear most people feel like even a
lot of liberals blame biden for gas
prices going high up
now we've seen two months of pretty
historically fast drops in gas prices do
you feel like it's something you should
give biden credit for watching them drop
no no
no biden's responsible for gas prices
going up
he's not responsible for gas prices
coming down
no i do not
i feel like he's
he's using our reserves
and uh
using our reserves to drop the gas
prices and uh
trying to find the word here to yeah now
gas prices have come down globally and
so that wouldn't be because of joe biden
and also
the reserves really can only by most
estimates cause a drop of somewhere
between 12 and 20 cents a gallon we're
now down over a dollar so not possible
that this is the explanation
basically fluctuate them just for a
short period of time then i think
they'll end up rising right back up to
where they were
um have you kept up at all with the
january 6 committee hearings and kind of
looking into
what led gen because you think it's kind
of stupid or what yeah
i just really don't see too much of a
point in it and
that's it so
riddle me this okay if you're on the
left and you feel like biden won the
election you look
that's what the courts figured out
that's what um kind of our official
processes
certified
and then you see through these
investigations that trump was doing
everything possible to try to subvert
what we would consider the rightful will
of the people based on the election
results and uh overturned the election
don't you find it pretty reasonable that
would be super scary and regardless if
even if you were conservative you would
expect people to be against a president
who tried to reject the election
necessarily with
[Laughter]
no no i wouldn't necessarily be against
that with all of the uh
with all the stuff behind the all the
election fraud i feel like
think he has every right to
say that it was not a fair election
even though all the court cases didn't
find that
yes i do
you think it
yeah i think it's a little bit corrupt
and i think our government's a little
bit corrupt and i think
it's a little bit really
covered it up really well yeah even
those trump appointed judges covered it
up which is really really crazy so
unfortunately more of the same and
remember everybody is allowed to vote in
the united states and at least some of
these people vote presumably um so scary
stuff and nice job there by luke beasley
you can find his youtube channel at
davidpakman.com
luke make sure you're subscribed
let's talk about vpn's virtual private
networks even if you're using incognito
mode on your browser if you're not using
a vpn everything you do online can be
recorded by your internet provider and
that is permanent because they're
selling it search engines social media
companies are also tracking your every
move you only need one thing to protect
yourself from all of it private internet
access one of our sponsors it's a vpn
it's simple you take a moment and you
download it you turn it on and you're
protected and you stay protected and
that's it vpns can also keep your
connection secure from hackers important
every time you check your bank account
or 401k or pension otherwise it can all
be out in the open private internet
access never records or stores user data
they've even proven this policy multiple
times in court their software is open
source to show that there's no data
being logged
this transparency is why private
internet access
is the vpn i use and my audience gets 82
off so you can stay protected for
and eleven cents just
month plus you'll get three months free
go to private internet access dot com
slash pacman the link is down below